today i have an
interview
with steve kaufmann steve comes from montreal/canada and was
also a canadian diplomat
now speaks 15 languages ​​although he speaks
his mother tongue english until 5
p.m. and he has developed the complete language
learning tool link i have the
chance today there are a few  to ask questions
you are very welcome that you are
there tomorrow evening the runners good
morning afternoon to canada well
let's start right away with the interesting question
for us was your surname kaufmann with a
double m a very typical german
name at the table that you have this
surname mean  parents were in
so not czechoslovakia because at
that time it was the idea of
austria not equal to kingdom
sometimes i say because i learned
russian and different slavic
languages ​​and then afterwards they moved to
sweden and then to canada
i come to canada assistant year
we are of jewish origin but
many jewish die  tell me that
jewish community in
czechoslovakia end in
austria hungarian kingdom were
german speaking are unconditional
cultural connection with so
german culture sport he was in
connection if i have a connection in
connection that means
two it means i have no relatives
in germany i just mean  that the
people so when i hear how my
parents spoke help their lives
in a small village in more then
it was a pure belonging
that was fun that was a part of
german culture but of course
we know that unfortunately there was a lot
a lot of history and as a
result this connection was destroyed it was
now i know there are a lot of users
who will come to germany again
and there is another
german i.e. jewish community in
germany
but i have no ties and i
am one too  gigantic jews a woman
comes from so svww we met
in india  If
the conversations corresponded between the levels,
do you speak them and why did
you decide to
learn them in the first place? I have I'll say I have
five languages ​​that I speak quite well
, of course, it's English, French,
Japanese, Mandarins and Spanish.
After that comes Swedish and now
though  i started russian the last ten
years
i think i speak
better russian than german now because i
have heard so much read so much
sometimes not spoken so much because
i only had to land once but
i hear every day i
really have to  have five languages ​​which i
speak quite well speak
5 if your anger and 5mg difficulties more
difficult skills now i have to
you once german i spoke the child
through in the 90s
because i did a lot of business
and a lot
i was always on the go with my
customers and and agent and we
were car sometimes stuck in traffic we
we spoke a lot of German and you can
hear you have to speak to the animals
anyway i can't tell i
prefer and whether the shorter middle five
or ten is different because for
now i knew for example that we
will have this interview
then i totally  heard a lot of german i
bought
audio books and e books fifa
i can work on the link especially with
new our new system that i can read on
my ipad and iphone and
save words and also save with six sentences
and and revision in my
diligence and so  I for very I
understand German very very well
I can understand this audio book this
excellent audio book
that is history of Germany from
1871 to today
and that I am very interested
but I never speak that's why
I like I can sometimes I ca
n't find the words okay the vocabulary
and i make a lot of
mistakes but never where that's roughly
say 17
18 i.e. tue  e series my language that i
might be the axis 17
but i think because i understand very well
i can read if i will
stay a few weeks in germany and austria german
speaking countries
then that would be
come back very quickly yes it is keen
that you extra yourself  prepared for this interview
hate and learned german
you have already touched on a
topic link the the platform the
app that you and your team are
developing together we have you can elaborate a
bit more how exactly
does the game work do you learn your
language
i think that in  learning languages ​​so
reading and listening a lot is
very very important and you have to have vocabulary
so now you have to you have to have a
very large
vocabulary because if you want to have so let’s
say no training for my so
significant language with new year then have
you have to have a lot of bock have because
the native speaker
so a German a  ber da canadian
knows a lot of words and he will use
those words if you don't
understand what he says you can't say no have
any
communication i understand
everything you say i sometimes have
trouble finding my words
but i understand and that's why i think
it is  always most important you have to
work on understanding and vocabulary first and that's what we do on the link
we need a lot of content in our
and i can find what i choose on the
internet import to the left and then
work for example i bought this
book and i  going to study on my
on my iphone on mainz
studying i read i hear i memorize
words and sentences i can do that on
meat career like you there is a
lot is descending dc system starting to know which words you like
you can and can't which  values
are new to you because there are a number of
functions, for example i will add
a new word there
can't meet
ok then i'll go to this i
'll go to the online dictionary right away
but as you know then i'll
forget that straight away
it's always like that you're looking for a one where
a after the words wolf's book
and then leave that and that's why
we have that will be highlighted
in yellow and every time i
hit that word again then
will that that will me that
helps me so to say
so noted otis there are a lot of
a lot of functions and and that
allows me for example i  in the
last round eight years i
learned russian czech polish ukrainian korean portuguese there what i spoke very little with
russian people there polish people and
so again but if i
do that
if i sometimes i will or was with
link we have there too  the idea
of
possibility to connect with native language creature and ask or i
will use for example i will be
active whom  den and there a twitter in
ukrainian search then all of this
preparation read a lot listening
vocabulary
so vocabulary after the big
one
that is but how do you say that
prepare me i have a very
big potential for me the main goals
or the most important that is that
understanding you have to understand if you
understand speaking goes very quickly
that's me there are many people who
believe that if i only
need 500 then i can say a lot
but it's not possible because it's always
like that there are a lot of words  that you
don't understand then you can't
break it
I can of course
have a beer at a bar please ok but if you
want an interesting let's
say with educated people have an interesting
discussion then you have to have
a lot of vocabulary mastered and
that we can do that  is let's say that's the
main goal look we have a lot of
statistics about the performance and
activity of our m  it elements like
that are all calculated automatically
and and that's also a thought
that stimulates people because if you study
alone you can sometimes still do a
bit
it's too easy to give up
yes that shows that you can't
or don't have to go abroad for a longer period of time
time to learn a storm
language works you can never make
plans and do it at home of
course it's better ok and that will
also be a goal i have for example
i studied for a few years and then
i wanted to go to russia of course
i want to of course
and then  i was in saint petersburg and
also in moscow but if i don't have
a certain level first then
i go to moscow that's why i go to petersburg
and i can't do
anything i don't want to do anything because of that i
think it's important that you have that
as a strategy ok i want to  example
do i have to study or daily that's it
himself with checke i studied for a year
and then i went to nac  h
plan
that should that was always my goal and
if, for example, some people like sometimes i
i didn't want to i didn't want to
study we have to do that when i
come to park i should have running
they say and it's easier but it
is and that's it  not every student
everyone loves so
wants to learn languages ​​doesn't have the opportunity
to go to the country that's not that's
not possible
and today with the internet
like for example it's totally okay i wanted to
learn polish then i have in our
mobilitec pool there  quite a lot of
simple material and i did
that and then i on the internet i am
looking for polish so was business i love history
very much so
then i have okay historia toski then
i was looking for that found this website
where you can buy audio books audio books and e
books books  buy and if I find
content there myself so listen and m
that's perfect for us
and then I'll import it listen
and read and  then i stand i can
create my own polish russian korean world yes and then
afterwards certainly a little
forward and lie down and then i will
immediately i get along very well with the people and
then my level will be
forgotten of course you tend to forget so thats not
interesting  approach to learning so you
don't hear many people say
you should speak quickly
so i always do that i start
speaking quickly
how would you learn a new
language in general so if you started
a new language tomorrow how
would you  you proceed step by step
ok it depends we have good he
so beginner content link or not if
we have there many begin begin that
means 30 seconds very short you have to
listen and read
ok i hear 30 i don't know then
i read every word
I have to look for it in Germany and then I
will hear that many times and
read it four times and never allm  So it will
be similar at the beginning I am absolutely not
and how I I can't hear when
a word ends and the next week
begins at the beginning that's just a new one
but after reading and listening to a lot
you found a bit of understanding
and it's possible  i will also buy such
a start book
the shots of a folder was it is
always convenient to have a book a
little boy but not too much and not
i will never explain the dramatic
so
understand to try it is not possible
because i have no experience  middle
language so the explanation has
seen
you have to start reading through this and
listen a bit to have a feel
for this language
then you can start reading the dd
grammatical rules so again
but not to tor either
i will not try this
though  to remember it's not possible it's
a gradual process and i
'm getting more and more difficult
for example linked the the inh  old people
we have this lesson
there are different lessons there are
things for example our
members have a short
talk with children or my wife for example
something 30 seconds very start simple
things up to podcasts up to
audio books radio broadcasts there are
many different things and
we always have one that says the
difficulty level is then
again indicated hundreds indicated and
then i will always be a bit
more difficult this will make it more difficult until the
time when i can
read and hear almost everything that interests me because that
is that is important  because it's very important
to anticipate progress because you have
to anticipate
and when you've had it that's
interesting then you're always
motivated to continue and
hear and read other things again
and that's why for example now
I have the celeste for example  cover
one week i heard a lot of
german and that was about gold deut  sche
story the skill of from peter
zolling and that is interesting i don't notice
that i'm learning the language i want to
learn this in hard and that's the
best way then if now for example
now contradict
i have a few years i didn't
speak any german but it  it
comes because i have the dogs who
understands you mentioned
that they haven't spoken german for a few years
so
overall the 15 speaks languages ​​at a
more or less high level so i
'm having difficulties keeping my six
languages ​​active  and if i
don't speak the language for a few weeks or a few months then
you always need a bit of time to
get used to it but this one with 15 languages
like shops until the how how do you keep them
active so you don't speak german for several
years so how do you manage
you the tactic to stick to the five
languages ​​i speak best then
it's no problem ic  h can very quickly
without but the german example
now i have to do a bit so for
me it's a question of reading and
building
you have to brain a bit and then it will
come back and you know if you
forget something and learn again that
is  very good for the brain
you learn it better when you try
to learn something we have for example
vocabulary one last try to
learn that it is very difficult that we
value it less and less effectively
it doesn't matter if you
forget something and try again  serious
and forget again is
that is so these
tests that is very good for the brain but for
me yes it doesn't bother me that for
example i have difficulties
speaking german now it doesn't bother
me i have a potential through if
i  would work again maybe go
to germany and stay there for two
weeks then it would be better
and if i have doubts it doesn't help
spoke portuguese for a long
time it doesn't matter i want
to start jumping on the train me a
lot of mistakes
i won't go it does
n't matter was but ddd simplest
answer is you have to read and
listen again in this language and if that
opportunity if you have the opportunity to
speak
you have read and heard a lot about it
and that you also learned your language
the fresh but how does speaking fit for you the
equation so shore leave
controls to speak the often you
speak it depends
so me  have an end
so 2015 i tried to
be a
celebrity three months that was a so called we
have we almost i do everything
sometimes that i am elected and the
whole camp of then effectively
i think and we would have a 90 90
days to challenge
challenge
ok the first two months i just
redeemed and listened so i have
link you will need a lot
saved and studied and there it is and
then in de in november that was the
marriage peter month december
i started talking to people
through the
internet that maybe a five
hour week and that that was
n’t exactly anymore you can’t average three hour
days at  skype example
and if i do it as a learner that
the first one is enough and if i will for
example if i go according to plan
i hired two different tutors there
and i we also have
members in prague so i
organized it so i have in prague  i was
born in the czech republic for six or seven hours a whole day i am not, for
example, traveling in any way and i hope that
i will have the opportunity the
opportunity to speak this language there
you can't do that you can't
talk to strangers yes i can speak to them in
the  buses with the attempt to speak to him
but it is possible you have to organize it so
that's true
but also with the internet we  nn you
travel to another country through coaching
internationally from whole people like
the couchsurfing itself but there are
many tenants in the last meeting media there
are words you always send
native speakers then again a question
about the languages ​​so I find that
some languages ​​are more difficult  than
others and i am also
constantly asked the question what do
you think the most difficult language is that
the simplest language and of the
languages ​​i speak i would describe
russian as the most difficult
and english as the simplest how
do you feel about it what do you say
the most difficult ones match what are the simplest
languages
there are 22 say the point of view so
first it depends on how far or
how different this language differs from
language
you know, for example, don’t
panic that’s why toni was very
easy
i learned russian then it was  it
simpler ukrainian simpler on from
ukrainian that is very simple  but there
is also why for me
chinese was very difficult was there was no
no vocabulary no connection that
is i want to learn all these words
to zero
but if for example from french
you can learn spanish because also from
english because there is 50 percent of the
words are of
latin origin so it seemed to be
very difficult but it is also the case that the
spanish language is very complicated
the grammar is very complicated
anyway the
main thing is motivation if you have to
be learn languages ​​and that for
example in canada that
all young people learn in school  people speak french but
they are not motivated that's why
it's very very little about
english speaking canadians can
speak french which i'm not
motivated that's why I didn't have
it with me says motivation
yes I can just agree so
if you are motivated and the language has
a small relevance then it is  it can be the
easiest to learn the language and the
similarity  i also say well the
french threw me another
challenge
i worked i learned spanish that was very easy for me because i
languages ​​are just so similar and have such a
similar structure then to the
last topic you have the north american
sports about mergers in canada that
taking place next week addressed you are
registered as a speaker why is it going
there and what you are talking about in your speech
i don't know for me this is a
new experience will see
i hope this is an opportunity for
people who love the language not only
for superpole bells  but
ordinary people who want to
learn languages ​​because i think there are so
many ways to
learn languages ​​today it's so much easier than 50
years ago 50 years ago
i learned chinese for example
and i will see in minden
what that conference decrees  i do
n't know but i will learn about the idea that the
importance
so through inha  lte that means
reading and listening was for me that's
the most important thing
we speak we come there if you understand
and you can also be political if
you don't speak because if you
use the language okay if you
read that's also a kind of
communication if you can  for example
understand a lot more and read radio programs
and and and books that is also
a that is a kind of use of
this language that’s why sometimes i
think there are polyglots they
try to prove i can speak a lot of
languages ​​eu commissioner’s camera was
okay so that means  not that
this person understands
for me the main thing is the mind
do you understand this language
ok and that europe i will become this topic
and i think it will be a
lively discussion was there are
people there who say what you have to from the first
day you have to speak and  I'm
against
it you have to speak when you're away and since
the ball is there if you don't understand
what like to say
and you don't have any vocabulary you can only
talk about the weather or what the car is
like or what your name is that's why they don't make
sense to me but when i have the
opportunity, for example if i
wanted to go to japan, i
tried to ride my bike from am  i tried
to use this language because i
wanted to there in japan
okay but mostly i
solved a lot and listening and learning
languages ​​from then with content with an intro
at the end were so it was also an
interesting approach whereby since i had
the problem  very much that many
never speak it so many say
even after years yes they still have to
learn this and that but if you read and listen to a lot of
content and
really want to use the language then it
works very well in any case
i can imagine
so  i think mostly excuse
me my german is sometimes difficult
sometimes i have to be very sincere
but there are people who study the
language is the  try for example
i got through with if i did at the
beginning i tried this this the the the
the trying to learn it is
impossible and if you just concentrate on the
grammar then it wo
n't work then who will you never
speak was the will  always things
that are not for him but if you
hear and read a lot then it will be like
that you will be assimilated ask then
you want to speak your time
will come i have to speak
now i want to speak and i will
never think about grammatical rules
i  want all these words and and
say sentences like me music i have to
use that and that comes naturally
i think but a lot of people who study in the
traditional way
they are afraid of making mistakes what they
are afraid of speaking
i make a lot of mistakes i'm not
afraid  i will use up my words
sometimes with would and i will not
get worse because if i would continue
to speak and listen and read
i will gradually improve better i
will not speak bad bad
then i would like to move on to the last part of
this internet
i.e. 15 languages ​​i speak 65 of them
we share one of them said
that germany now i would like to
do the remaining
four languages ​​english  french and
spanish with conversations a few a
bit of small talk
perfection
the french newspaper thank you
very much and was very okay we see
something good